[Music]
okay i'm ready
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream 119 cues coupled
with a's
it's like that that is it's it's like
that okay we're gonna we're gonna be
brief today guys sorry about that we're
gonna abbreviate this just 45 minutes
that's the goal okay let's get right
into it discord question from this week
you have mentioned that you are not sure
who or what are the forces working so
hard to suppress certain covet-related
information
off-camera are you talking with people
to try to figure that out any headway
under what conditions would you share
new understandings of it what are the
risks of making this discourse public
yeah a i don't know that there's a whole
lot of
uh productivity to be had in
trying to pursue that information you
know it's obviously powerful forces we
we know that because of the uh
the reach that they clearly have
we can tell more or less what they want
we could probably infer something about
who they are
based on
uh the nature of what they're
pursuing but you know i frankly i think
the best
the best deal is to assume that you have
some dedicated actors you have some
emergent properties you don't know the
admixture
but figuring out what it's trying to
accomplish and how to
reveal it
is where the productivity is figuring
out
who exactly
uh
i'm not sure we're in a good position to
do it and i don't know how much value
there would be i mean obviously
there is a large network of people
downstream of fouchy
okay leave it there
um
there are a bunch of questions uh wait
wait one thing that said there was some
excellent uh work done that revealed
where
some of the suppression of the ivor
mechtin story was coming from uh it
wasn't our work that stuff is public um
you can check out
it was um
it's got a great sub stack um
i'm not gonna
nothing is working my computer i'm not
gonna be able to find it okay well
suffice it to say that
take a look around there there was some
good stuff that emerged over the last
couple weeks about the uh andrew hill
review can we talk about this analysis
that um well we've talked about elements
of it but anyway there
there is smoking gun-like evidence about
who exactly was muscling andrew hill
yeah
um
i guess
i thought that we had specifically
explicitly talked about this but maybe
that was a different a different forum
um
all right
nothing nothing is quite easy at the
moment on on this device
um
so now i have to find my way back to
the q a there are a lot of questions
this week
a lot of comments
mostly from two people
about ukraine okay
and um
one of the people writing in is
ukrainian
and then one of them does not specify
but um seems likely not so i'm just
going to read them all
but i guess i will preface it by saying
uh it is
what is clear
is that
almost no one actually has a good beat
on what is going on and that we are
definitely in the realm of miss and dis
information and uh male information to
some depending on which government it is
that you're speaking on behalf of
um so that is um
it's it's impossible for for most of us
to know um
the truth of what is going on
so
um
someone who presents themselves as sasha
says i am from ukraine
uh
rf which i think means russian forces uh
attacked us
history repeats itself with the genocide
russian federation yeah attacked us
history repeats itself for the genocide
of ukrainians like holodomor i want to
spread the word about ukraine
uh
says then
um
so these these are not in the right
order unfortunately and i don't know how
to get them in like the right
chronological order
maybe i can do it this way
sorry
um
sorry guys um
okay
here
here we go um
i'm gonna read all of sasha's and then
um the one other long comment from the
other person about ukraine
marxist ideas spread so wildly when my
ukrainian father woke up from the
bombings
a teen from the us had written to say
that the ukrainians deserve it
he is a communist the teen from the u.s
i'm somewhat extrapolated because i also
received a letter from from this person
so i'm so the language isn't totally
clear in these in these comments
um continues
oh actually so here's so okay so here's
someone else writing and say does anyone
else think that zelinski is a warmonger
with smolette syndrome that's jesse
smellette benefiting from the victimhood
of war incentivized by the us instead of
de-escalation zelensky responds bring it
on in response to putin's demands while
his peeps die
the u.s mainstream media promotes this
defiance by conflating it with being a
war hero and furthers the narrative by
showing pictures of him in arms in a
hollywood-style fashion the media
instead of no-fly zones
um
he should de-escalate evacuate and
negotiate
sasha writes if we surrender there will
be no peace
my family is on the killing list of
russian terrorists since 2014 we have no
option but to fight
mario paul is destroyed my brother
fights in kiev
um
and i think that's it oh wait no
poland 1939 ukraine 222
please educate your followers on the
history of world war ii
so that's
a lot of comments on ukraine and russia
and the current situation
yep
i would just say
the
overarching sense that i have is being
frog marched towards a narrative whose
purpose i don't understand and it
doesn't mean that no aspects of what i'm
being frog marched towards are correct
so i don't want to assume that i am
being fed the opposite of the truth but
i
the the sense this term frog marched
did you just make it up i hope not okay
i believe not um
it's like it's like perp walking but for
frogs um
okay
the
the sense that i have is that actually
we have a hypnosis problem and that the
population has been hypnotized it didn't
work on everybody
but
there's an extent to which the hypnotist
has you and then he keeps choosing
topics
and a lot of people were hypnotized on
covid
and now people are hypnotized on ukraine
it happened so rapidly and the
level at which americans
are
focused on
war in ukraine
is conspicuous right it's one thing to
be focused on a war you know we've had
the experience of having wars that we
were participants in
in which americans were not focused it
was like it wasn't the us has not right
no americans have been in this situation
and now we are in this opposite
situation
and it is clearly about there's always
wars going on that i mean you know
that we don't aren't paying any
attention to but of course a war in
europe no but i mean wars in which we
were partisans in which we were fighting
in which americans were not paying
attention this happened in the aftermath
of
9 11 iraq and afghanistan right these
became background and this has been very
foregrounded even though we are not
fighting in ukraine
yeah i mean i don't think that's quite a
fair comparison because we're still in
the early days so you know years in i'm
not i'm not excusing any of this
but years in yes the fact that we still
had
uh american men and
even some women fighting in afghanistan
and iraq was backgrounded um but so too
happens to every story after it goes on
for a very long time
i don't know i don't know that that's
normal i don't think that that was true
uh
for vietnam
i know less about korea but i don't
think it was true for korea either
something has happened and the way in
which we get information has left us
vulnerable to a hypnotist and this
hypnotist has
you know there was a position
that we were supposed to land in right
we were all supposed to have ukrainian
flags in our bios and we were all
supposed to imagine
uh that zlemski was
a handsome hero who just so happens to
be able to dance or something
um
and that uh you know putin is a simple
monster who had no
uh
no reason other than
avarice to
attack ukraine
uh and it's it's the comic bookification
again yes simple heroes simple villains
simple superheroes simple supervillains
i think you nailed it it's the comic
bookification which tells you that the
story is serving a purpose that has
nothing to do with informing us
and
the the idea that world war iii a
potential nuclear exchange with with
russia
is a possible outgrowth of such a thing
the parallels to
you know the cuban missile crisis
uh in reverse
the whole thing is designed to get us to
cheer for something i don't know why i'm
supposed to be cheering for it
i know that we have that the stakes here
are incredibly high and that that ought
to be dominating our thinking rather
than a comic book version of
you know um pluto attacked popeye
um
so yeah no and it is part of why
uh
i have found
wisdom in constantine kissim's analysis
uh half of the trigonometry duo um
in part because he has
family
both in russia and in ukraine
and so he you know he he has both skin
in the game at least family-wise and uh
and an ability
and and views you know
people close to him who feel uh
opposed to other people close to him
with regard to their analysis of what is
going on so he you know he has people
that he knows how to assess what they
are saying who are saying things that
are the opposite of other people whom he
knows how to assess what they are saying
and that provides a kind of of lens that
is very rare
i i value
his contribution for that reason he does
seem to have nuance he has insight on
how this could play out he sees the game
theory pretty clearly
also i would say
there is the fact which i think he
shares with us
of having pointed out
how our vulnerability in the west was
inevitably going to lead to the
exploitation
of our weakness
yeah and you know we've been pointing
this out since 2017 in public that you
yes you can play games all you want with
sex and gender
uh and race and mathematics and science
but you can't do so without making
yourself vulnerable to
right people in the rest of the world
who
recognize weakness and
cultivate their own strength and take
advantage of you when you're
distracted
yeah
so yeah we're busy pretending men are
women and um it's a it we we do not look
like either serious or a strong people
we are not we are not and i i will
repeat
that
if you want a society in which you are
in a position to experiment with things
like
gender then
you do not weaken your
military strength in the world you need
a a masculine a strong masculine
military to protect your right to
experiment with
uh important parameters at home rather
than just declare
that this is the new wisdom and it will
be imposed across everything at all
scales which is the height of insanity
indeed
okay next question
john mcwhorter calls wokism a religion
with racism as original sin
is vaccination a purification ritual
well i will draw my usual distinction
here i don't think these things are
religions i think religion is a
time-tested cult and the point is these
are cults
and just like you can't write a myth you
can write a narrative and if it is time
tested it becomes a myth
uh that effectively there there is a
it may be ryan bennett who coined the
term a religion-shaped whole
um there is a religion-shaped hole in us
that gets filled with something
it can be filled by a cult and the cult
can be predatory or the cult can be
let's take
mormonism for example yeah
right the beginning of mormonism you
could argue hey that's just a cult
it's you can't say it's just a cult now
right it is actually
it has stood not a long period of time
but it has stood the test of a certain
amount of time
it has uh
it has it has
accomplished things that suggest
strongly that it is a religion yeah um
but anyway the point the point is look
the vax thing
is
a cult
and
so many of these things fit that rubric
including wokism very clearly
but
it is it is important to distinguish
between the time-tested article and the
newly emerged
uh foolishness yeah
could wind farms block or redirect vital
trade winds and really screw things up
uh
i hesitate i don't think trade winds
right i think trade winds are higher
but um
currents you know
wind farms are lower to the ground i
don't think trade winds are higher you
know because i think trade winds are
named that because of their blowing of
sailing vessels oh
um
but
okay you're right you're right so let's
put it this way any time if you're going
to address a an energetic problem of
planet earth
with some kind of solution whether it's
solar panels or
windmills or whatever it might be
in order to get the kind of scale you're
talking about you are talking about
disrupting the underlying process from
which you are taking energy whether you
get across a threshold in which that
matters is the question right
and you know
there's an awful lot of tidal energy for
example uh heather you used to talk
about the possibility of
capturing tidal energy and the point is
the tides flow in and they flow out
you can capture a lot of that and not
mess the world up well presumably i i i
think actually there's a there's a risk
of messing up um
uh
the organisms wherever it is that you've
got those big turbines oh i'm not
i'm talking about global processes yes i
mean you know windmills kill bats and
raptors and stuff like that you disrupt
lots of stuff with these but you're not
going to screw up the tides you may
screw up the mechanisms in the
particular place where you are
but you won't screw up the actual tides
because you can't do that by putting
stuff in the water right i mean let's
put it this way you're taking energy out
of water in motion but there is so much
water is so dense and so
so much energy is represented there that
it's almost inconceivable that you could
drain enough out to substantially alter
the underlying process
um right
less so but still
still it seems like scale wise it's
unlikely on the other hand as we warn in
our book
at the beginning of a process
where you are in no danger of
changing something by virtue of scale
you ultimately could scale up to a place
where you do when it's important to spot
that possibility yeah no i was looking
at something when you're talking but i
think you alluded to
you know gas is compressible you know
air is compressible and so you could you
you will more easily
move aside wind than you will move aside
water um
by by running it through a turbine yep
um
i'd love to hear your views on the
morality and legality of abortion love
you both
uh i am going to because we're trying to
get through this quickly i mean you you
are welcome to speak as much as you like
here brett but i'm going to direct you
to this piece which i wrote in 2018 are
you in there zach yep you want to just
show my screen for a moment
um
so i wrote it in august 2018 on abortion
time space error and ethics
and um i stand by what i wrote then
which is to say that i am um
pro-choice but um
i
i would hope but i know that it's not
true but like everyone who is um
for choice would like to minimize the
number
of occasions uh when such a choice
should need to be made
yeah i would say this is a incredibly
complex issue most reasonable people
come down
in an intermediate position where there
is some
right to
terminate an abortion a terminated
pregnancy very very early while we're
still talking about you know
cells
and there is some point in which it is
too late to do so in good conscience
uh obviously in hunter-gatherers there's
even been infanticide
which was not done lightly
so the point is we are in novel
circumstances and we can afford
limits that are narrow and protect our
humanity from our technology
that said
one of you know i don't think this
argument is well addressed because i
think conservatives are saying something
that liberals either can't or won't hear
about what happens
to us when we have control over
reproduction at a certain level and
obviously i believe
reproduct control over reproduction is
essential for things like the equality
of women it's essential for planning a
modern family
right rather than being hobbled by
uh children it is essential for rapists
not to have a way of spreading their
genes there are lots of reasons that
it's essential but
i do think we radically screwed up
civilization by not recognizing how much
hinged on the previous logic before we
had
reliable control over
birth and that we have done an appalling
job of figuring out what we did to
ourselves what the net effect was and
how we might mitigate the harms we've
just done a terrible job
yep
why do we not simply allow trans women
to compete against trans women and trans
men to compete against trans men
uh
the main reason is there aren't enough
right i think we do um
they're not enough so these competitions
don't exist there aren't enough so the
competitions don't exist
but i don't think anybody's stopping it
yeah but
no one's stopping it there aren't enough
but the
you know the unfortunate secondary truth
is that some number of people are
some number of trans women are competing
in women's sports uh precisely because
it confers an unfair advantage to them i
mean the the
the lia thomas example is
unfortunately very very clean
this is a person who competed as a man
and didn't win
declared themselves a woman and is
winning
it's not like
declared themselves a woman
and discovered a new sport and i was
like oh let's see if i can also you know
be an athlete as a woman no
this this was a man a young man who was
an athlete who wasn't winning he was a
middling male athlete who became a
championship
trans woman athlete
not a female athlete
so
obviously if there were actually enough
trans women and trans men in all the
sports to compete um that would be the
thing to do
uh but
you know they just aren't enough
yep
given how much of ideology is based on
emotional insecurity what do you think
of the idea of free access to mental
health services for all
um i wish i thought mental health
services were on average helpful i was
just gonna say i know of um
i think i've mentioned this before
i my oldest dearest friend is and i know
of another
that makes two
clinical psychologists i know of who are
extraordinary and who are do who are
helping people who are just doing
extraordinary work in the world and i
assume they're not the only two
but i you know it's great i think i
think we know a couple of others by
extension yeah i i think so too and you
know there's lots of excellent work that
happens not within that that narrow
framework of like clinical psychology
right you know there's
there's
there's other work that happens that
just isn't called that but
given
that
given that the market drives mental
health treatment
in the west
and it's far easier
and cheaper and quicker
to
run down your list of possible diagnoses
check it see what pill to prescribe and
send them out the door
that's the nature of mental health
treatment in too many for too many
people and that's uh clearly
actually and actively
disempowering and bad for mental health
rather than the opposite yes modernity
puts the mental and mental health
in
a a legal sense i tend to think of
marriage like a corporate merger we
organization around a union of assets
mobile mobile might brand as exxon or
else hyphenate like exxon mobil
um
well
obviously there's room for a re-branding
you could yeah i mean i mean i think um
i think the piece that's missing from
that and it sounds trite and i'm not the
first person to use this but i really do
believe in the um there's now three
entities
uh and
uh
you know three entities each of which
have agency and interest
and you know two people come together
and those two people still exist and
they are hopefully and presumably
transformed by the partnership uh but
the partnership is its own thing and you
know in in our case i am my own thing
transformed and affected and changed by
you but also my own thing and you or
your own thing transformed and whatever
the other words i used were by me and we
also um you know co-build the thing that
exists
neither
more in you nor more in me which is our
relationship and you know that
no i can't name the individuals the
three individuals there aren't three
individuals there are three entities
my individual refused to make all of the
jokes that you set me up to make because
i'm better than that
but you're not
a little
it's probably too late the timing's off
oh do you want to make one absolutely
not yeah i won't do it on principle yeah
you can't have it both ways either
they're gone or you're not doing it on
principles well i didn't do it initially
on principles and now the timing is so
egregiously bad that i don't do it on
that principle it's two to separate
principles the principle of
self-degradation
not wanting to self i
i resist the uh the desire to self i i
hear enough crickets as it is i i i'm
not gonna inflict crickets on myself are
you kidding right now it's the frogs
that are ringing yes it's springtime
here oh
um excuse me why do you use the term
lived experience is there unlived
experience and if so is that also a
common term seems off for some reason
yeah you know this isn't this isn't our
term it's not my term hi
um it's
you know it's what people are saying and
it's it's it's used
stupidly it's used and in fact we heard
this at evergreen when evergreen blew up
um and even we were beginning to get
intimations of this in classrooms
beforehand where people were actually
arguing in an academic setting no less
that
uh
scholarship that thinking that science
that evidence had no bearing that the
only kind of evidence in order to assess
something like
um you know what is the history of
native americans in the united states is
the lived experience of extant native
americans like that is the only evidence
that's possible you can't use analysis
you can't use methods that have been uh
derived by granted maybe you know dead
white men um you're not allowed to use
that it's only lived experience that's
that's backwards and and to
anti-academic and anti-intellectual and
just
anti-reality
um that said
uh i i therefore and i think i say it
more than you do um i will use it as a
sort of a nod to of course there is a
place for and of course we do uh we do
find interest in the questions that we
find interest in which we may then
investigate with for instance scientific
methods
because of the biases and developmental
experiences we've had which together
comprise our lived experience
now i'm realizing
in this morning
the paradoxes here are so many but okay
so they de-platformed these
burrito-making
white women in portland yes um for
cultural appropriation burritos not
being native to their lineage
but it seems to me i mean i really feel
like what we were doing as professors
was democratizing
the tools of science that yes happen to
have been innovated by some
white european dudes but isn't that the
point i mean if the idea is you're not
you're not allowed to appropriate
burritos from latinos if you're white
but given that the white dudes you know
engaged in bad behavior that put them in
a position to have an enlightenment you
want to take the best yes shouldn't we
be appropriating their scientific tools
i mean isn't that the right answer yeah
that's my lived experience by the way
it occurs to me you probably don't want
to do this in the q a but we did not get
to one of the things you specifically
wanted to talk about in the first
in the first session you mean the fact
that i have been
permanently and most extremely cancelled
yeah yeah um yes it's not the right
place to do it okay i have uh i have uh
suffered a near
fatal cancellation
it really wasn't that bad but it's it's
it's remarkable it's remarkable yeah it
may it may show up in the news i don't
know but um but yes
um
stay tuned we'll talk about it next week
uh if i have um
i don't know what do they do i guess you
know canceled is the stage before they
declare you
uh guilty of malinformation terrorism
it's the one guilty is did you say what
is the statement they cancel you yeah
and if that doesn't work then they
declare you guilty of malinformation
terrorism which avails them of all sorts
of no i think they already have found
you evidence of that and that's the
basis in which you were canceled
oh
no no no no no i don't think so at all
because in order to in order to convict
me of mal information terrorism they
will first have to admit that what i'm
saying is true which they haven't gotten
around well so they're convicting you of
misinformation terrorism does sound like
them yeah yeah fill in the blank
information terrorism
exactly your prefix here information
terrorism right we've settled on the
fact that what i'm saying could make a
person distrust their government we just
are disagreeing over whether it's true
or false and at the point i win this one
then it will be mal information
terrorism
that's right that's right um when did we
start zach i said we were going to go
for 45 minutes was it 11 45
yeah right about a half an hour
okay
um
119 isn't prime but it is a semi-prime
the product of two primes that's cool
whoa yeah am i gonna have to start
checking for that
apparently
would you ever do a podcast with dr
peterson and professor jonathan height
totally sure yeah um
please explore oh this is a tiny little
question please explore the evidence
which says that sexual orientation is
immutable
oh
um
there ain't none
um or it's not very good because it's
not so immutable yeah it became i yeah i
don't know the history um
i don't know the history of thought on
this but we sort of we lived through we
happened to have lived through
and i can't even tell exactly when but
early in our lives sort of the point at
which it became the thing that you
understood that this was that you know
born this way right um as opposed to
uh the effect of um you know parenting
this that the other development whatever
and
frankly it wasn't something that i at
least i think you had but i i just
went the sort of born this way
line didn't give it too much thought and
then it was actually reading douglas
murray's
most recent book uh the madness of
crowds which is excellent in which he a
gay man says
actually yeah
i'm not so sure about this and frank and
i don't know if he says but i sort of
get the sense that he goes i don't even
know where the evidence is right well
it's also i don't know
multiple things one
it's very hard to have evidence of this
given that we all have a period of years
before we can articulate anything like
sexual orientation and we don't have a
clear memory of those very early years
so who's to say second of all there is a
fair amount of evidence about events
that change sexual orientations
um third there is the very fact of
douglas murray and you would be
surprised how many men tell me that
they're not gay but that douglas marie
makes them think twice about it
it isn't it is not an i i've never said
this but
it's it's not an uncommon thing for
straight men to say
are you serious
all right i may have said it a little
more extremely than they say they say
things like if i was going to be gay
then he would be just my type yeah
exactly that's that's what you get from
straight men
i don't care
you know
he's a pretty cool guy he's awesome
absolutely what i hear is straight women
going like man
oh too bad that guy's gay
right yeah okay
um which frankly
is easier to get to than what what
you're claiming i agree i find it a
surprising thing but i have heard it
more than a couple times okay
okay
um
i just had the question
where did my question go oh here's a
comment okay i had it quite oh here it
is but here's a comment first your q and
a's remind me of car talk
your mix of whimsy and deep systematic
knowledge is great two notes could you
have a weekly puzzler can be submitted
by listeners and could add employees
like statistician margin of error margin
of error man it's been so long since
i've listened to cardhak in fact i met a
couple of um women this week
um one a portlander and one
her sister who lives actually up in
olympia awesome it was great great
conversation i don't know if they're
watching but um
and i said something about back in grad
school i listen to hours of npr every
day and it's been years years since i've
been able to listen to any of it but
card talk was one of the things i i
lessened and one of these one of these
sisters
uh mentioned how much she she loved car
talk and i'd forgotten about marge
ginabera margina
a weekly puzzle i can't remember their
puzzlers though i'm having a hard time
remembering what they were
they were they were automotive primarily
right
oh
you know yeah they did we have to
specify like an organismal puzzler or
something right yeah i i like i like the
idea of the ones you know and i like i
like um
i like this we have to i'm not gonna
i don't know we're not gonna develop the
puzzler now but i like the idea yeah i
like the idea
okay um
please provide it back this is the
question i was looking for which isn't a
question
please provide a backstory for each of
the catchphrases eg goliath first
against the wall club ferchered on
featured on the merchandise in the dark
horse podcast store
so
uh did not touch anything anymore
uh
so one of them is
uh
first against the wall club yeah first
against the wall club uh which i must
say has caused some consternation but
the basic idea is
that your fear is being used to
manipulate you into doing the bidding of
powerful entities that are
dangerous to your planet your family
your descendants
and that at some level
at some point you're going to have to
stop cowering you're going to have to
stare into the abyss and you're going to
have to say you know what i cannot
protect myself from these people
you know i can make myself safe in the
moment by not
crossing them but i can't make myself
safe in the end that way so i might as
well
um
call their bluff
stand up
might mean
uh
to take the uh
lyrics of one of my favorite songs
which i will leave oblique but people
can can search it up
um
uh and if you come for me some night you
better bring a shovel and be expecting
the worst
because i got you in my mind's eye there
you go
i don't know the song it's a good song
but anyway yeah i probably know the song
i don't know what what so staring down a
frightening enemy is basically the point
um yeah yeah
i'm going to just look at a couple more
because the question was explain
uh
your algorithms no good here
yeah um the idea being that we are all
being manipulated by
uh entities powerful entities that use
algorithms to shape our
um our mindset and that
one
you owe it to yourself to your family
to your friends to have a mind that is
not
easily
manipulated right to remain independent
and to render their malware useless
indeed
then we have uh goliath written in
google font and colors the back of which
says don't be evil we've got that
covered
uh well that sword there
hangeth still above the dark horse why
because google
demonetized us and threatened to purge
us and has still not re-monetized us has
basically gone radio silent
on the question
and you know that's them being evil
and trying to stamp out
voices that they don't like so
anyway they are functioning as goliath
and
goliath you will notice is not a person
in modernity he is a giant
collective and david surely we will be
too of course if you go back in to our
earlier podcast you will find
that david
is the construction david is a real
historical figure but his
showing up as goliath's uh antagonist
is probably inaccurate that it was
elhenon who actually fought goliath and
then elhanon got wrapped into david's
character yeah
uh okay let's just do two more um not
questions but things from the merch
store um that i'm finding as i'm
scrolling through we have saddle up the
direwolves we ride tonight
uh well we ride tonight as a actually an
allusion to another another excellent
song
um
what is the title of that song um
i will think of it
uh but saddle up the direwolves is
obviously
a bizarre reference to the game of
thrones yeah which direwolves make a
prominent appearance over settled never
saddled as far as we know
and what was the last one
oh the uh epic tabby oh the epic tabby
well is he not though is he not epic oh
he's sweeping something about
the epic unassuming
tabby cats basically
a
regularly occurring kind of cat mutt
that often has incredible
characteristics they have some great
personalities they're very innovative
and uh insanely smart yeah very smart
and so anyway there's something about a
just a really high quality rescue animal
and extremely snuggly
especially
in bed after having been outside
and having collected paws full of dirt
did it to me again last
night dirted up the bed
okay um
there's a number of
questions here that don't i don't
understand what they mean i think
there's some words missing
um
so let me just i'll read two of them we
have a couple moments if track record
isn't on the judge's scorecard
shouldn't we focus on what is
um i guess this is a reference to i
don't know
um
no because the point is
yeah you can't win the power game
through merit and you can't win the
merit game through power that's really
the point
and so and it's the people who are
already in power who made the categories
on the scorecard so right and they claim
to be playing the merit game and the
point is it looks like they're playing
the merit game because they're shutting
out anybody who's playing according to
the real rules of meritocracy and so in
some sense the point is okay you can win
the game but uh it doesn't make you
insightful yeah
so track record is the way to tell
okay we'll do one more here
hi what is your opinion about novavax
versus immunity via infection in terms
of risk benefit does the protein-based
facts change the equation
um
i have still not looked yeah i looked
into lenovo x months ago and have not
reminded myself of it my sense was i
wasn't that excited when i looked at it
i had trepidations yeah i would also say
i don't think
you know i think we do know that there
was a campaign to obscure the value of
natural immunity
but i don't think we know anything about
how this works long term
right i don't think we know what they've
just signed us up for by
running out the clock and allowing this
to become endemic i don't know
what the variance game looks like in
light of weak and weakening vaccines and
i mean to the extent that natural
immunity is extremely protective
as the virus continues to evolve um it
can evolve out from under previously
acquired natural immunity and in fact
omicron has been widely discussed as
and and anecdotally we've heard lots of
stories of people who did get covered
once in 2020 2021 and then got it again
once omicron came through yep and even
worse the
stupidly broad tropism of this virus
means that if this thing does that trick
where like the common cold it mutates so
that you get the common cold regularly
because you're effectively dealing with
new variants if it does that and then
each time it infects you all sorts of
tissues which aren't really involved in
viral transmission but the virus doesn't
know any better than to leave them alone
are damaged and the point is this
becomes a serious health crisis and
um
you know even beyond what it has already
been yeah so anyway yes these the people
who mismanaged this
uh the cost of what they have done wrong
is incalculable
it is
okay uh we're gonna
cut it there cut it there so that we can
uh not
miss
our
fairy um yeah
all right all right so uh
thank you for showing up earlier this
week if you did and we will see you next
week at the normal time at 12 30 p.m
pacific
and
i'm sure there are more things to say
but we will just finish with be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you